good afternoon everyone
uh quick could Ikea to get us off today
is
[Music]
oh
welcome again to our meeting here today
I will eventually change that karakia um
it's probably gonna give it the same
saying but we'll get there eventually do
I have any apologies I have recorded
apology from councilor Reed
any other apologies
looks like the rest of us are here
uh could I get a mover that we accept
the apology for cancer read uh cancer
Stringer and a secondary Council Dixon
all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
conflicts of interest cancer Havel I
wish to declare a conflict in relation
to item six dealing with the delegations
to commissioners
thank you counselor councilor Dixon
um I'd like to clear a conflict as well
on item six is a commissioner
thank you councilor any other conflicts
thank you moving on
uh
we have confirmations of minutes
the first being the good district
council meeting the ordinary meeting
held on Tuesday the 13th of June
did we have any questions in there
could I please have a move that those
are true and correct
counselor Richard mcfail seconded by
councilor McDonnell
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
secondly confirmation of the ordinary
meeting Gore District Council held on
Tuesday 27th of June do we have any
questions
no could have a move that those are all
true and correct uh Council Dixon
seconded by councilor hovel I will put
the motion all those in favor please say
aye
and against the motion is carried
third is the policy and Regulatory
committee meeting held on Tuesday the
20th of June
any questions or comments
could I please have a move these are
true and correct
counselor Stringer
oh I think these ones are to accept uh
the minutes
sorry but uh Council Stringer to move
second
uh Council Dixon
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
and the last one there is the
recommendations
oh yes so that was sorry just the
clarification that the recommendations
be endorsed in that one as well are you
happy to move and second that that was
understood thank you
uh and then same with the community
wellbeing committee on Tuesday the 27th
of June
um the only one I just wanted to pull
out of there
uh is on page 33
so it says and that the council
establish a working party to assist
staff in the preparation of the draft
Reserve management plan
a councilor's comfortable appointing a
working party here today
and if so do we have any recommendations
of who should be on that working party
thank you you worship um and and
following this discussion the um item
that's above that on the bottom of page
32 I need to talk to
um so the the intent of having the
working party is is to give some
governance overview of of the process of
looking at the reserve management plan
and um it is something that I would Keen
to be a member of that working party
um and um uh I'll leave it for anyone
else who wants to speak up I have been
approached by another counselor
thank you councilor councilor McDonald
so Council McDonald and I I'm also Keen
counselor councilor Dixon would like to
be a part of that
are we happy with four members on that
working party do we feel that sufficient
thank you counselors so I will put a
motion to that effect
um in accordance with the acceptance of
the rest of the recommendations uh in
these minutes
uh which would be or would you like me
to make it separate Council level
separate okay let's do the
um let's do that first so recommendation
that the council established a working
party consisting of uh myself councilor
Havel councilor Dixon and councilor
McDonald
to assist staff in the preparation of
the draft Reserve management plan could
I please get a mover for that
recommendation Council McDonald and
second advice councilor Garden I will
put the motional as in favor please say
aye
and against the motion is carried are
there any further comments from
these minutes uh Council oval so at the
bottom of page 32 there's a
one that reads at the council resolve in
accordance with Section 41 9 of the
reserves act secret and suggestions in
terms of section 41.5 of the future use
of Reserve areas now that that part of
the
reserves act
um is saying that in effect during the
preparation of a draft
that Russian suggestions be sought from
the public
so just just to avoid any confusion that
might arise I I would like to have that
amended so that it reads that the
council resolve in accordance with
Section 419 of the reserves Act
prior to completing a draft
Reserve management plan
that had seek written suggestions in
terms of section 41.5 Etc
just so that this avoids any confusion
thank you councilor
Susan did you get that I'm not sure if
you can thumbs up or something
did someone get that you got it cool
fantastic thank you
did you have is it okay to be pushed
through with the rest of the minutes yep
uh Council Dixon sorry can we hear the
recommendation please
easiest coming
um Council
resolve in accordance with section 41.9
of the receiver 1977 prior to completing
a draft Reserve management plan
to State Britain said in terms of
section 41.5 on the future use of
Reserve areas
perfect well done
thank you any further comments arising
from these minutes
could I please have a mover to accept
these minutes in the recommendations
that they contain uh councilor McDonald
and a seconder
councilor Paul mcphail
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against
motion is carried
urgent late business do we have any
urgent late business
appears to be none thank you councilors
number five the gore District annual
residence survey
were there any further updates from this
report from the communications general
manager
foreign
sorry about that delay we have
representatives from research first
um on screen who will be able to I
thought will be helpful if he maybe talk
to counselors through the way we run a
residence survey and just some of the
findings and answer any questions that
elective members may have
thank you for that uh and yes welcome to
John and uh Petra is it
uh did we have any questions from
councilors on this report
maybe if we could invite Josh just to
um lead off if you like Josh and um Step
us through the process
ing methodology
yep
um so in line with previous years This
research was conducted by a telephone in
online survey
is conducted between March 18th and
April 27th of 2023
um there's this research achieved for
total of 661 responses from residence
within the core District
380 Watts were conducted by a telephone
surveys so telephone interviews are
ideally suited to surveying a large and
geographically diverse populations such
as Gore
maybe one on our responses were
completed during online survey and let's
ensured that everyone that the community
who wanted to have their opinion who was
able to do so
you can pull the telephone to that it
was randomized with only each household
a quarter system was used to ensure that
the sample was representative of the
population and won with the 2018 census
we did this by putting Target ranges on
the collection of residents by their age
location and gender
contents for quantitative market
research it helps us understand how
reliable and accurate the results of SWR
and provides reassurance that we can
reflect opinions onto an entire
population
so what the expected me is that we can
expect that if we were to do the survey
knowing about 100 times 95 of those will
reduce results that are with within a
range of plus and minus five percent
meaning a 50 unsatisfied we can be 95
percent soon I'm there between 45 and 55
of the entire population also feels this
way
also in line with reports that you get
to 2014.
um when we analyze results we first
clean them while we're moving or don't
know and not applicable responses
results are being measured and reported
on using one or two methods so the first
method is what was called total
satisfaction this is the proportion of
residents that aren't so neutral
satisfied or very satisfied
coming on the bringer which is the
proportional residents who aren't
certain degree or strongly agreed to a
particular question
so the Board District Council we stood
their research
ERS and in order for our findings to
remain consistent work studies prior to
research first when we first undertook a
research
so the top one in key findings of This
research are as follows so the best
season of the research focuses on
Council Services double standard noodles
onto satisfaction
so we've done that 86 accent solid
Wastewater Services which was consistent
with last year
64 unsatisfied with stormwater systems
which was a significant decrease of 20
from 2022
uh satisfaction with reliability was
found to be at 86
um satisfaction of the quality of town
Water Supplies
and significantly satisfied with local
seal roads so for these three services
we observed a drop of between four and
five percent from last year
greater than our five
year meaning the weekend of Supply we
say that these differences are
significant from last year
all three of these measures were
consistent with the findings from last
year
and we didn't mean and asked wisdom to
dissatisfied with one of those Council
services to just explain a little bit
more around what is it that is causing
their levels of dissatisfaction
residents we're commenting on their
dissatisfaction with the poor and
variable water qualities that they had
been receiving
28 reasons we're coming on they're just
satisfaction of the condition of the
past and 18 permanently on their
dissatisfaction of the quality of
Breville roads
some examples of what people were
talking about you'll be able to send a
screen but you know
only and the camera just need to get on
and fix the roads there are a number of
potholders within roads incredible
and really in their opinion it just
wasn't enough to scratch
the next section of the research focused
on Resident satisfaction with Council
facilities so allergy and living
facilities that we wish to go on in 2023
10 of them were consistent with last
year and continue to meet their
performance Target that are set in place
all
the one facility that failed to meet its
Target was satisfaction with other
toilets well
made by silver percent since 2022
this result also represented the large
and the lowest level of satisfaction of
these facility since researchers and
surface racing in 2014
similar to Services we recently asked
with our residents so we'll just
satisfied with the facility what what it
was that made him well what was that it
was impacting them and causing them just
had surgery
observed signatories Library Services
were all like meant
and actually there were actually a
number of residents who suggested the
need to provide more facilities at the
aquatic centers within the district
some examples of these comments uh you
know there was just a need to tie up the
roads around the cemetery as
shouldn't really be looking nice for
women breathing getting these coming to
visit
some comments about the need for
facilities that economic centers of this
one on the right so it's just the need
to upgrade the toilets other than the
everything empty producing potentially
what we're doing but it's just the need
to obtain some of those facilities
good exception focused on understanding
resonance perceptions of normal
you know knowing out of the team agreed
their Gore that big old district is a
great place to look
is good for sporting and recreational
facilities
over three quarters for each center
community and especially wear it as they
are living
three quarters of three then four
district is a safe place to live
and in 74 percent ago a great sense of
Pride on the way their local area looks
and feels all five of these symptoms are
consistent with 2022.
and the final key section of the
research focus on understanding
resonance perceptions of the performance
of the cancer
what that's uncovered was that 86
percent were set aside baking content
and a link to the member of the council
to raise
that's what's consistent with last year
and again since we're also said so
[Music]
it seem to be set aside that the catalog
is responding to the knee
should raise for them with aluminum
was going to decrease significantly from
last year where it was studying at
around 66 percent
was satisfiable performance of the
old leasing about eight percent since
last year which has been a significant
degrees
all the last ones are all on our
agreement scale that I talked about
really which uses only equity and
strongly free responses and doesn't
include unusual so 41 percent will agree
that broad District Council provides
enough opportunities for business to get
them safe
19 felt a bit veneer in calculus
displayed sound effective leadership and
20 agree that they have good strategies
well the councilors with strategies were
developing prosperity and well-being
within their communities
three of these agreement statements
we're going to decrease significantly
from last year
we then went into looking in to
understand reasons to satisfaction with
their local leadership we Australia came
down to three key reasons which
attributed to
personally found that sixty percent of
dissatisfied reasons stated the issue of
council employing that have you had
something new man was elected
team seemed were disappointed with how
the council was run and the lack of
fresh ideas council members you know and
staff that make happily Council and
honestly the common of the attempting of
the dissatisfied residents stated that
the new mayor of enabled
experience to play the role well
an example of agents audience the
similar spring water I mean they really
just talk about how it's important
they're not getting along with the deal
with them here and it's a bit of a shame
and then all comes
all comes to put on personalities and it
was just getting council's stuck in a
place 2013.
thank you very much
thanks Nick Josh for that presentation
do we have any questions from councilors
councilor Garden
it's just for the survey with telephone
contact
is that using hard wires or cell phone
for the rowers or is it because a lot of
rural people now have dropped their
telephone number and they just use cell
phones
what's your comment on that thanks
and through mobile numbers
thanks there Josh and thank you
counselor any further questions
uh councilor Paul mcphail
um look I would just like to
congratulate the staff and apart from us
sitting around the table everything
looks good so we're all done to the
staff thank goodness you're doing your
job thank you oh and the other comment
the public toilets I don't think they're
as bad as what the comments are are you
do a lot of walking and use the toilets
at different times and I don't think
they're that bad so maybe it's just a
couple people so let's just tune in I
want to say Well done
thank you counselor
any further questions
no we'll move into comments does anyone
have any comments around the table
Council Dixon
thank you Russia
I thought the survey brought up some
interesting comments and data one about
that the waste Transportation
satisfaction is higher the curbside
collection is very important to the
community and it's interesting that
people are traveling to riversdale to
um to recycle
the goods also that the elderly would
like an Avenue for their green waste
which I think is something that we could
look at and that the rural people are
also interested in waste and what can be
done in the rural areas
um interesting that antenna is becoming
more popular and online services are
trending up which is which is a good
sign
uh the Aquatic Center 95 satisfaction
which is really great for that Center
the satisfaction with representation to
me was dismal and statements like
residents that are satisfied with
councils performing performance
suggesting conflict between council
members I think that's quite
misunderstood because the council
members do not have conflicts or
disagreements we all get on very well
together and I think we all work very
hard because we've come from
employment from employees we all have
families and I know the councilors turn
up for all the council meetings when
possible and committee meetings and all
the outside organizations that counsel
rep centered on so I think we all do
work very hard and do our best for the
community
so the overall the managers and staff
can be really pleased with the survey I
think they've done very well as
counseling Val has said
the only other comment I could make is
is there other options for our review
um just going into next year whether we
could look at different ways of
reviewing
people
thank you
thank you councilor councilor have out
thank you your worship I have previously
prior to being elected to council
expressed concern that the way that a
number of the results are shown in the
reports particularly the way that
neutral
comments or responses dealt with
um but because of the um additional
information that's given in the
background papers you're able to drill
down and have a look at it a bit closer
and an example uh relates to local
gravel roads where we're told that 66
percent of the people in the district
are satisfied with the state of our
Rebel roads but if you look at the the
results in detail those who are
satisfied or very satisfied is only 22
percent which puts out a different
signal to the 66 percent that shows up
in the overall results and similarly
those satisfied are very satisfied with
sealed roads is 36 percent and those
satisfied and very satisfied with the
footpaths is 39 so it's sending a clear
message to Council on those areas is
something that we need to look at
there's a number of things that have
been trending down over time and I'll
talk about those in a moment
but probably the issue that jumps out
for many people is the responses with
regard to council's Performance and and
it is something that we have been
turning our mind to in recent times
where councilors have been having
discussions amongst themselves and with
them here in order of having a working
relationship that is fulfilling the
expectations of the public and we are
making progress in that area
there are a number of things that each
year
have been trending down and when I
raised this issue previously I was told
that
it's something that's taken into account
when
um annual plans and that are looked at
and I'd like to assure the public
there's an issue such as public toilets
storm water
and and the local roads that it is
something that I will be exploring in
some detail on the long-term plan to
ensure that we actually have a better
performance in those areas
there were comments made in terms of a
lack of recycling and again that's
something that we need to be looking at
closely as part of the long-term plan
with regard to recycling we are working
together with the other councils in the
region through waste it at looking at
having a coordinated approach in the
region and the waste net body will be
making some announcements of that as as
it works through that and I'm speaking
in my role as the chair of the wastenet
combined committee across the councils
the um
issues in relation that what councilor
Garden raised about people no longer
have telephones more people are using
cell phones highlights that we've been
doing the same old same old in terms of
the techniques we've been using to
contact people
and Reliance on telephones asking the
same questions from year to year I think
the time has arrived to have a bit of a
reset in terms of
looking how we do the survey the methods
that we use we're now Reliant more on
cell phones more on social media
techniques more on Council dealing with
people directly by way of example the
questions that are in there relating to
the district plan are no longer for
purpose and we'd probably get a better
indication if we're doing live
questioning of people following receipt
of or good people going through Council
processes like resource consents going
through building consent if we actually
surveyed people that have been using
those processes soon after they've
finished them we would get a better
indication of how people feel about
those Services
I also doubt that we need to do it every
year
um and and wonder whether we need to
explore we've done it this year do we do
it again in two years time
um before this this Council
um uh progresses on um with the next
um election
um and it's something that I think we
need to explore as well as the other
questions we're asking
um for purpose uh in terms of where
society's at things have moved on
um so to I guess wind that up in in
terms of what um uh councilor Dixon
commented as well I think we need to go
back to First principles and the way
that we're looking at the satisfaction
survey there are a lot of good questions
in there that are still relevant
um but there are questions in there that
maybe we need to be thinking at afresh
so whether that needs to be done as
emotional something that we look at as
part of our long-term plan process I'm
open to some guidance from the chief
executive thank you
through your worship
um it's an area that I've given some
thought to as well because uh we're a
small district and by
approaching the residents with the same
roughly the same package of questions
year and year out there is a danger of
survey fatigue and
I guess a lot of the stuff is born
around the performance measurement of
the annual plan and ltp and orders is
looking for evidence of how you know
that you're delivering services to the
satisfaction to people you serve so
hence that's why some of these measures
are in place too if you like report back
on that
um I'd be certainly like to take a
conversation up with our Auditors about
whether we could
have biannual
surveys to still meet our our
obligations in terms of reporting on how
we've performed
but the method by which we
both survey people and the questions in
which we pose differently are up for
grabs the suggestion of the likes of
regulatory processes and asking users
how they're fed has a slight danger and
that if someone doesn't get the result
they wish through possibly deficiencies
in their in their process they may not
give you a stunning report card
counselor
um so that's probably just something to
be aware of
um but in terms of first principles
review refreshing and asking questions
whether we could hold it on a bilingual
basis I think there's those discussions
are timely and it's something that we
can gear ourselves up for
um because of course just past the
annual plan just last meeting and we
will have to
in 12 months report against that annual
plan
um and so the question will be asked
well do we rely on the data that we've
just secured today or do we have to
survey the people again in 12 months
time so that's a good question
thank you Steve and Council
thank you for that feedback from the
chief executive I do hope that he in
referring to buying yours was in fact
thinking of biennial surveys
um yeah once every two years rather than
one twice a year
thank you Council Council mcphail
thank you worship
um just a few comments here there little
discussion
um obviously time's a great thing and
looking through we've got a number of
issues that have been canvassed in the
survey I take it on the nose in regards
the residence commentary regarding the
council which I include obviously is
worship and all the counselors as the
council it's a benchmark that we don't
want to be in and we are moving forward
on that so probably the biggest thing
that we can sort of indicate from that
point is that there's a huge amount of
energy and effort going in with both the
council and our worship in regard to
working with the staff and the community
and to give them that insurance it's a
benchmark we don't want to have a
measurement and go back to
um moving on to the other matters there
um in regard to the uh obviously the
roading and I think councilor hotel's
picked up on some very valid points
there they are a focus we do have the
working groups we do have limitations
there it's it's a continual thing that
we do get in our surveys these are the
the same things time and time again and
maybe we do have to look at Reinventing
or look at how we do focus on it and how
we actually remove ourselves from there
um I'm not sure I don't have a I don't
have a wand where we can find bags of
money to go and fix our um unsealed
roads I know with the recent weather
pattern that we've had there for those
who live in the country we've got some
fairly disturbing surfaces out there and
I know that it's not on a uh wanting to
fix them it's actually prioritizing and
working out where we get our best bang
for buck
um in regard to the toilets just a
couple of comments here I agree with um
councilor mcphail the older that um
the the toilets when I use them being a
country member I do have to go there and
uh
most of the ones I find are in a good
State probably the thing I'll point out
that whether it's because of covert or
lockdown I think a lot of aim and some
of the explosive expletive stuff that
seems to be happening I have concerns
what happens with some of the use and
some of the toilets I've been into but
in saying that I'll come back to um
Neil's commentary in regard that toilets
aren't very exciting but I think that
some of the people I've seen use these
two ones were probably reasonably
excited about getting to them it's that
the the the the state they're in uh just
closing regard to the toilets
we we obviously have the measurements
for mobility and the ones that we go
into there's clearly ones there for
people with the mobility issues so we
have got a reassurance there because I
see that is formed part of it that
there's um some toilets that aren't
meeting that standard and whether that's
ones we've got to address or they're not
um I think Matera may be in a situation
with the toilets at the park there there
and Mobility capable or
they are okay but if it's been addressed
in the survey maybe it's something we
come back to
um
other than that uh to the staff there's
um some very take the uh dissatisfaction
Parts out of it uh to the staff
congratulations on some really good
commentary in there some really good uh
outcomes around some of the services and
or majority of the services we're
providing there
um the only last one I had there was
around Library maintenance I wasn't sure
what they were referring to that the
library needs maintenance if we're if
we're there already we've got some
issues but um yeah but that's all I'll
say on that thank you worship thank you
councilor very good summary
any further comments from councilors
Council McKenzie
uh just to comment on the lose because
of where I am situated
often you'll see one or two buses
pulling up there and people are lined up
on the street waiting to use them now if
a person went into the year after that
you can understand why things might not
be just 100 percent
the off chance that somebody's gone at
the wrong time after there's been a
couple of buses there because you see
them winding up waiting to get in just
wanted to check that comment in there
because I don't think they're really
that bad they might be the old time when
those buses are there have been there
thank you
thank you councilor uh Council Stringer
uh thank you worship
um through you how do these
Trends and figures presented presented
to us compared to what else is happening
around the country at the moment
Josh did you ever uh maybe a comparison
potentially
we're also seeing a lot of
dissatisfaction with the council itself
I think the way that
I guess New Zealand and the world what
the things that are happening right now
the cost of living and inflation a lot
of people are dissatisfied and that
often leads to the sanitized with the
individual councils and their local
councils
thank you
thanks Josh and and think it counselor
any further comments
yeah sure just so you wish that one
comment
um I would make about the survey
interpretation and it's something I know
that Sonia and I have discussed in the
past and that is the use of the the term
neutral which is puts you in no man's
land so does neutral mean that you're
kind of happy or kind or not and I do
wonder where that's actually uh thwarted
a decent analysis by having because it's
usually a decent chunk of people you
know 30 the same or 25 are landing on
neutral and I wonder where if that
choice would remove and you just had
very satisfied satisfied slightly
satisfied slightly dissatisfied you know
to satisfied very dissatisfied that you
might get a more accurate picture of
where people are actually land in terms
of a view on any particular service
yeah
thank you for that Steve and you know I
think there's a emotion forming around
how we do it next time and in
conversation with the auditor and also
conversations around the long-term plan
is there any further comments
I thought I'd just touch on a few
comments
um
and and I I think they've been kicked
around by by councils a bit but it
definitely saddens me that uh that our
person just sits at at 19 there
um while it's somewhat not surprising uh
given the incredibly public Journey that
uh we've all been on around this table
since the election last October
um we can't change the past but I do
feel it is important to provide the
public with an update on where we're at
and what we're doing and I think Council
mcphail touched on it
um we must apologize first and foremost
to our community for the erosion of
trust that has occurred and as a parent
in this report
um
we we've spent to as as Council mcphail
alluded to we have spent a large amount
of time over the last few weeks and also
months through facilitated conversations
and trainings
um reflecting on the learnings that we
have had in these first nine months or
since October
understanding what mistakes we've made
but also how we can do better
So currently we're in the process of
preparing these learnings and agreed
ways forward for a somewhat of a public
release not only so that we as
counselors can move forward as a
collective but also so we as a community
can understand the journey that we've
all been on and how we'll work together
from now on and try and restore a bit of
that trust and confidence with the
people that we serve
so a 19 satisfaction scores in no way
shape or form uh something to be proud
of but it is a clear indicator of how
our community is unhappy with our
performance and we need to do better and
we will so I just wanted to put that in
there um as I said in there there will
be some more some more learnings um to
come from that but we are definitely
having those conversations internally
and trying to provide for our community
did we want to formulate a bit of
emotion around
steps forward with with this review
potentially around some questions for
audits but also looking at it as part of
the long-term plan that's kind of what
I'm hearing
Council stranger
oh it's so we leave it into the
long-term plan side of things
yeah agreed uh did we want to formulate
some questions but auditor is the
Tuesday could have comfortable having
those conversations and just kind of
feeling out where they're at
yeah through your worship I mean and the
long-term plan you will be looking at
your performance measures and the means
by which you measure that so that will
be captured uh the long-term plan won't
necessarily capture the process by which
you'll survey people but it can be
included in discussion uh and certainly
we can take it out with the Auditors
about the need for annual surveys or
whether we can do it by annually to if I
would
um and and we can come back to the
council with that because I'm a complete
an agreement that there's a danger here
of survey fatigue without the community
um so but we can take that up I don't
think it's a motion is absolutely
necessary the minutes will record it no
doubt and we'll act up on it
thank you Steve uh and yeah we totally
agree I think there's a
there's a big conversation that we need
to have as a council around how we
communicate with our community
um moving forward and I'm sure a survey
will fall into that conversation
with that being said could I please have
a move that this report be received
uh councilor mcphail signal by councilor
Phillips
any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried uh
thank you to both Josh and Petra for
zooming in really appreciate it
on to items 106 now commissioner
appointments uh and we have uh Katrina
online
and Matt as well I believe
thank you would you like to speak to
this report at all
um
your worship Jess addresses two
practical things so one is to
um
there's a recommendation and then
Keith and Bell be granted the RMA
hearing Commission of delegations that's
one it's SMS to decide
but Patrick report is read but
I think that Katrina do we have any
questions from the floor
uh there has been one question uh raised
by
um one of the proposed Commissioners and
and Katrina may want to speak to this
matters in the recommendation that at
least three Commissioners sit on the
proposed District plan hearing uh there
was some questions around whether that
threshold should be larger two uh
because in some hearings there may be
not a lot of contentious matter or there
might just be two
specialist type commissions that can
quite comfortably deal with the subject
in hand so Matt or Katrina you might
want to just answer that particular
question because it does go to the heart
of one of the recommendations that
before the council
interesting
Pinterest quite met with your thoughts
on that one
that one sure uh 3D worship
um
we've come up with free because
ideally you want to get a consensus
decision but that's not always possible
so having three each other
next month you could go to one but at
this stage it's a bit unpredictable
because we haven't notified the plan
we've got the submissions been through
the further submission process so it's a
bit hard to determine how many hearings
we're going to need and what the
scalable because
and they've got their day jobs to
still manage so I think three gives you
the ability in
Council of representation and some
you know an independent planning
commissioner and also a management or
representative
things that would there be any concerns
with having two
um Commissioners as the as the minimum
so at least
um
it's not a significant issue
with a as I see that it's always good to
hear the model number in case there is a
dispute because we're trying to get
ultimately come to a consensus and then
we can't
have to go by majority ultimately
yes for you your worship
where they always recommend odd numbers
way possible
which is week three comes from it's not
so you can't do
it yeah thank you for that clarification
I I guess
I'm just reading it as a bare minimum
needing to but I would imagine that any
any
conscientious decisions where there
might be a split vote probably you would
expect that there would be three or more
whereas Tower is kind of a bit more
mundane
ability for it with you it's it's just
because most people aren't available and
it's not particularly the most difficult
situation but that's that's just how I
would
um interpret it but open to discussion
on on that point in particular
do we have any questions
uh Council Stringer
it's about that particular point you
worship or other questions uh for the
for the whole report oh okay
um look I just want to
um
might have a bit of relation to that but
you've got cheering indoors we've got
two councils that are chair and Dawson
one that's not what would be the
relevance of that Turf the the
if we had two lips uh or sorry
um one couldn't have tens that's not
chair and doors does that have any
effect on it
so you might find
planning and dependent commissioner that
is Cheer endorsed and then you can have
a counselor that's not
it as well for example
thank you
and so just the clarification so either
either
Cliff Bulger or Keith Haverhill would
need to be in attendance
um for that for that hearing to go ahead
because you might engage
thank you for that
any further questions
right into debate do we have any debate
around any of these issues
doesn't appear to be
uh
did we have any councilors leaning one
way or the other around potentially two
or three Commissioners our standing
orders would permit if we were to stick
without standing orders that the minimum
Quorum is two
um however this recommendation here is
for three did we have any opinions
either way
I think I'd be happy with two but then
in any sticky situation I think you
definitely need three you need the odd
number and how do you know when there's
going to be a sticky situation as the
problem and you can see situations do
tend to come up
is it is it going to be a casting vote
for
the chair of a of a hearing panel we're
getting quite technical now but
a provider the council standing orders
provide for a casting vote and they do
that would then endure to the hearing
panel
in terms of contentious issues through
your worship look it's um
it counts The Gardener has a point a
good point and throughout my local
government career sometimes the genders
you think are very benign or Hell break
Solutions long debates secure but when
plenty matters I think the district
playing committee and I'm sure councilor
Gallo can speak with some Authority on
this that there were one or two matters
that were signaled early as being
they're going to require some heavy
lifting and some decent debate
I don't think those issues have
disappointed and are likely to be
probably prominent in the submissions
that are received and the issues that
will have to be determined
you sort of agree with it after today's
being
I think that Stephen and counselor I I'd
also I guess like to take note of the
last recommendation whereas my
understanding that the chief executive
has final say on those panels anyway so
I would imagine that
they wouldn't there wouldn't be two
Commissioners allocated to quite a
contentious District plan yeah it would
be relatively sensible there the the
only thought that comes to mind around
having two and then a casting voters
that gives that one person a lot of
power
um because they can just overrule the
other person
um
but I would imagine that situation will
be
foreign few between
I guess and I'll go to your Council
thinking on the Fly having two
commissions means that there's it's less
likely to be held up trying to get that
third commissioner um and as we try and
keep momentum with this District plan
um I would hate for hearings to be held
up because we are struggling for
availability
but it's just a thought cancer strung
out to do yeah
Council mcfar
it's just really worship but obviously I
would be the same for the expediency
factor that if there was two to to
um to work I would support that and
obviously practicalities are that we
still have the final recommendation
there that if there was a pending storm
that SCE would would work out if we
didn't need that third third there so if
the uh you know I probably are on that
side as well
um it is a difficult environment we work
and now just add that that we you know
to get people together and
um as I think Matt indicated um
the working environments and people
working trying to get everyone on the
same place at the same time where we
don't want to um hold up process
thank you councilor uh councilor
McDonald
oh Mike
I think the wording here lets you that
at least two if you had at least two
Commissioners then you know you can get
your third that stops that problem if
you only can get to it a particular time
I think it just gives you that extra
flexibility so I'm supported as well
let's try and move it on if we get into
a sticky situation we'll tackle that
then
sounds good counselor
um I wonder
whether we need to put it in line with
our standing orders just for that
casting vote though
um so that the Quorum for the proposed
District plan hearings are the same as
permit in the standing orders something
to that effect
through worship music for belts and
braces and Clarity that would be useful
to have that in there yeah although
you'd be loath to use it but you've got
it at your disposal
councilor's happy with that wording
Susan did you get that
Colt thank you for that
uh so with that recommendation being
changed uh and all of the others staying
the same did we have a mover for that
recommendation
uh councilor Phillips seconded by
uh Council Stringer
any further debate on those I Council
got on
does that meaning we are going to have
two yes yes we should repeat the um
motion things
so I think Susan's crafting I don't know
whether she wants to jump in but it will
be
um that the Quorum is in line with the
golden shoe Council standing orders
which is two um with a casting vote for
the chair
is that about sounds what you got Susan
thank you for that
thank you
happy with the Mover and second uh any
further discussion
all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
welcome back councilors
uh next up we have a presentation on
biochar from Mr Dylan Graves welcome
if you wanted to jump up the podium here
um Paul did you just want to grab the
microphone
can I invite everybody to stand up if
you'd like to just have a quick stretch
[Music]
stretch
my thoughts
all right
okay who's got who's got the stopwatch
ready
go for it I'll get it I'll get it
running go for it all right so I'm here
to talk about biochar and hopefully
you've had a look through the material I
sent you in the email but if you haven't
I'll go through the basics again real
quick so biochar is when we take biomass
say for example wood
we heat it in a really controlled
environment where we can control the
temperature and we can control the
amount of air coming in contact with it
and we aim to volatize all the things
inside that biomass and allow them to
burn off
and we do it in such a way that we get
left with a large as large amount as
possible of the carbon left behind
okay that carbon is then known as
biochar and it has a very long life it
can only further Decay if it gets burnt
so if we put it into the soil if we put
it into concrete if we put it in any
kind of place where it cannot get burnt
it effectively then sequestes that
carbon
very conservative
time periods in the soil would be 100
years but there's documented evidence of
biochar being put into soil from tens of
thousands of years and it's still there
okay
wise biochar really good for the soil
well where all those volatiles have come
out of the biomass we have nanotubes
so Millions trillions of all these
little tubes inside that carbon and in
there it basically acts like a sponge so
water can go in there nutrients can go
in there and biology can go in there
so it's like a massive big party Hotel
all this biology having this great place
to go into the cation exchange capacity
of biochar is such that it attracts all
sorts of different
um
chemicals so it is really good for
holding nutrient so what that means is
before we put it into the soil we can
add nutrients to it
we can add life to it
and therefore you've got a way of
putting the life out into the soil and
putting nutrient out into the soil of
course if you don't put nutrient into it
then it can be used as a way to actually
collect in excess nutrient so I'm
thinking things like where we have
excess nitrogen fertilizers for example
but if you don't add the nutrients into
it then if you're putting it out saying
to agricultural Fields then it'll
actually hold on to some of the the
fertilizers that are being put on
and then release them slowly so plant
roots will go into them go inside the
Char and actually go and get them when
they need them so it's a way for for
Farmers I guess to use less
fertilizers
and that's a quick summary of what
biocharid is very complex it's quite new
it's only been around people haven't
really known about it for the last 15
years or so so there's an exponential
number of academic papers on it and
it is quite complex like I said but I'm
happy to try and answer any questions
the reason I've come here basically is
just to bring awareness to it because I
think it has plenty of potential uses
in agriculture but also in in other
things like putting it into roads or
into concrete and
what I see around when when I'm driving
through through agricultural areas
there's a lot of a mentality of we have
a waste product that we need to burn to
get rid of it and so what ends up
happening is that we have these big
piles of biomass
look from underneath and they just smoke
for three or four days creating a lot of
air pollution and we actually have way
too much of that unburnt CO2 in the air
anyway so what I'd like
um councils to do hopefully is to
promote seeing that biomass as a
resource rather than as a waste
and the waste just to burn it and get
rid of it let's see it as a resource
let's educate land holders to see it as
a resource and go for burning it from
the top down because if you light the
fire on top and it burns down the Flames
come back up through it as it's heating
up and they burn off all the smoke so
you get probably 90 less smoke if you
like it on the top
and then if you quench that burning Mass
when the Flames have kind of died down
if you put a whole lot of water on it or
a whole lot of soil on it well then
you're left with biochar at the end
and then you can put that into the soil
various ways conventionally through
spreading like you would lime or
fertilizer or you can mix it in with
compost
you can put it into tree planting
exercises and so on feed it through
livestock and so on so it's actually
quite easy to get it out there yeah
how's that for time bang on time thank
you very much though and that was that
was very unfortunate informative and
very well spoken do we have any
questions uh Council McKenzie
you may have already answered my
question but can it be used to clean
water
yes it can be used to extract nasties
out of water yes definitely so if so if
it gets wet it just doesn't turn to Mud
or something like that
you know definitely not no
um we you you'd crush it up and then
you'd need it to be in some kind of
container some kind of bag or something
like that and then allow the water to go
through it and then yes it could hold on
to heavy metals cadmium things like that
so
it could be something we're doing with
storm water to to try and clean it up
especially if it's in an area where say
yeah petrol station that's leaking
petrol and Diesel frequently
we put that in the in the drains around
that and and stop that going out into
our waterways for example interesting
good way yeah thank you
thank you councilor Council Dixon
thank you you worship I was just
wondering if you can Define wood trash
because I know there's a lot of branches
and things of trees are actually used
for wood chips now which in in boilers
so do you mean light hedge cuttings and
things like that or can you define that
yes biomass is basically anything that
was living
so biochar is getting made out of corn
cobs sugar cane waste when they've
harvested sugar cane it could be straw
all the way up to Big Tree Trunks so
yeah pretty much anything and
yes the future is going to be a lot of
wood energy so we're going to have a lot
of pelletization of Woody biomass so
in a way by a child's kind of competing
with that and it's gonna but
to me the obvious solution there is that
the the wood energy people if we can
convince them they need to sacrifice 20
of the energy and then we take that 20
of that carbon we put it away we take it
out of the carbon cycle uh for for you
know you know
for Humanity for for a climate
mitigation type thing
um
and hopefully they can get paid for that
because they get paid for the carbon
credits of that 20 and then maybe
hopefully someone can see the benefits
that that's going to do to the soil
and so people will want to pay for that
20 or so to put onto their fields or in
their trees or in their compost or so on
so
yeah
again that might be something that you
guys can influence if you're looking at
a consent where there's um a conversion
from coal to biomass you could say to
the biomass people well can we sacrifice
some of that 20 say and sequester that
and offset
um carbon emissions and do some real
sequestering
hmm
fantastic uh councilman last question
very interesting I I googled this and
went into looking I got off on the full
sorts of the street I was in South
America for most of the afternoon
looking at the the the use of the carbon
is it being used here now and and the
benefit for the soil structure to be
better soil as well as the sequestion is
a two-part thing isn't it because you
can have poor poor soil it becomes much
better because I just wanted to know
whether that's been is it being done
here now
sorry yeah
yeah
um so biochar can improve both sandy
soil so it holds moisture really well
and then it adds structure to clay soils
so it actually benefits both
and then what it can do with the the
life is give biology uh back to the lot
back to the soil and plants can access
that trees can access that
um the current situation in New Zealand
is that we're quite far behind
there is a massive potential for it I
sent you that link to the Headley report
it outlines all the different scenarios
of where biochar could be used in in New
Zealand and it's it's pretty recent
um what is happening is that there is a
massive big mountain of by a child that
was made by mistake from one of the
biomass boilers up in Rotorua I think
and basically their biomass boiler was
set up incorrectly and so the
the stock was going through too quickly
and so they had this product coming out
this black waist and they just literally
just pulled it up for years and years
and years and someone
who's into biochar discovered it and
figured out what it was and tested it
and that's actually pretty good via
chart and so he's using it
um mixing it in with his compost and
selling various blends of compost and
biochar both on small scale small bags
but also you can buy it by the
but cubic meter and so that is going out
on some trials and Vineyards and
various other small scale trials we need
more funding for this and and part of
the issue is that there's just not
enough awareness and so that's why I'm
giving up my time going around to
councils and just putting it out there
and and seeding the idea and I'm happy
to to follow up with any of your other
committees or any questions you have
please contact me I'm in contact with
the biochar New Zealand
um Association but they have no funding
they have no no paid staff at all we're
all doing it as volunteers just trying
to get the word out there yeah
thank you councilman thank you very much
for the Dylan it was very informative
and a great presentation all right
cheers thank you
just can't read that might quickly uh
next up we have the choice of the
electrical system and a big welcome back
to Rick's
um hope that your travel went well and
it's good to have you back
uh would you like to speak to this
report at all no
um we will take it as read do we have
any questions uh for the general manager
on this report
right oh do we have any debate
pretty straightforward
yes Council McKenzie
just the two different systems
is there a massive difference in cost
of running them
without doing a an in-depth assessment
um based on what other councils have
have done when asked that question as a
council of our size with the election
the size of what we would be used to it
would be maybe a few thousand dollars
difference
thanks Rex
thank you councilor councilor haval and
then Council Australia
I wonder CC Thinking Out Loud whether we
should be making a decision on something
like this without actually giving the
opportunity for the people that elect
counselors to have some input
thank you counselor Council Stringer
thank you worship and I agree with
councilor Havel's statement there
um
the other one was going to be in
relation to
single transferable vote the councils
that use that do they get any better
turnouts or public results from it
would be difficult to answer that
because they've only well and run system
so you can't compare what it might have
been of Dunedin city council for
argument's sake ran a first pass to post
system when they run a single
transferable vote so it'll only be
speculation there are other supporters
of single transferable vote who will say
it gives you a more diverse
voter but again it's it's only
speculation because you're not comparing
at that point in time in terms of the
comment around
basically asking the community you have
to make this decision if you choose to
go and ask the community you just have
to let this lie on the table go out and
ask it we don't have a resource to
undertake another mini referenda to
um
get assessment of a survey of the
community I'm looking at our engagement
manager
to run something which at the end of the
day you will have to decide whether you
want to first pass the post system or a
single transferable vote system you can
do that informally by asking your
constituents and your
normal Communications and like I say
that would be just putting the decision
on hold to come back with something but
I certainly don't have resource to run a
run an engagement campaign or a
referenda to identify whether the
community wants you to decide a first
Pastor post or a single transferable
vote system
yeah
thank you Rex thank you counselor
any further conversation
uh Council mcfowl
if just through your worship
um I'm quite comfortable to uh
look at this obviously we've got the
communities familiar when you look at
what the system we have it exists as an
elected member no one has ever asked me
about a change in the system at present
it's not something that's been laid out
before me in discussions or Community
discussions so I am happy to consider
the recommendation that it's here today
on the merits that have been stated
um just in regard to the notice it's
given with that too there's also the
notice of right for
full community public to to come back
isn't it in regard to the council
process so I think it's actually um
there's a one each way there anyway for
anyone who is a bidding me
and also take on board that um as
possibly another loading and in our
consultation process uh community
with the community which clearly
um we're getting indications that the
staff is probably reaching its point of
not that that needs to be
experiences should be taken in there but
I think we do need to take into
consideration for this recommendation
thank you councilor
any further comments Council Dixon
thank you worship I'd just like to say
that um we did have STV for District
Health boards and people found it very
confusing I mean I don't know how many
times I had to explain the system to
them and I think first class post is
very clear and people understand it from
central government elections as well how
it works
counselor
um I think on that point around STV I
think it's referred to in the future
local government documentaries I think
it's ranked loading which makes far more
sense than STV because when you think of
rent voting it just it seems a lot more
um
applicable in your head I I do wonder
I'm cautious of the time frames that
have been outlined here but just in
terms of tabling this report I do wonder
whether we might be putting the car
before the horse here slightly
um this is to do with the representation
review and STV makes no sense in our
district that contains a lot of
um one member Wards we have
three one member Awards um and then
District wide is only is only three so
so ranking them really wouldn't make a
whole lot of difference would make no
difference in those with with only one
member uh however if we are to make uh
drastic changes in the representation
review
um not that I'm indicating that we will
but say for instance we changed her to
urban and rural Wards or make the awards
bigger or smaller it might be easier for
for councils to then debate which system
um because as I said it's very clear-cut
first past the post at the moment but
then if we change the awards
um STV might make more sense so is there
any danger I guess forming into a
question is there any danger of
notifying one option we go down this
pathway we decide different different
words and have to switch the the system
you have to make a decision by the 12th
of September for the 2025 and 2028
elections
if you change through your
representation review process
um
uh how how your members are represented
around the table
it will be Revisited after the 2025
election
it's a quirk in the statutes
thanks Rex uh Council mcfarl
through your worship things just the
other thing to think about too is
obviously making a decision on behalf of
the material community board as well
so that's something that we've got to
think about are we doing what they want
and that's possibility that we need to
ask and go through that process before
the time that we made to make the
decision but just a point
yeah I think it's a very good point to
raise Council because in the instance of
the community board it would make more
sense for a ranked system you have five
members so you it would be a lot easier
in terms of voting to to rank your most
favorite um councilor McDonough did you
have a comment there
well it's not uh very hard for me to
comment on this I've been elected and
opposed twice we can't even get two
candidates in my Warden three times
before that I think the previous Council
from there was elected unopposed so
whatever system you use it's going to be
cancel over
if we make a decision then my
understanding is that a request from
five percent of the lecturers then would
trigger the need for a poll if I can ask
how many electors do we have for the
district please
through your worship are not exactly
sure but we I know we have six thousand
two hundred and fifty yard rate payers
um that that wouldn't be electors
we'd have to go through you we'd have to
go back to um election services and
actually ask them who's on the roll and
to get a to get an accurate answer to
that counselor I don't think you can
speculate on a number of ratepayers
versus because a lot of people can vote
who aren't ratepayers as well yeah so
and and the reason for asking that is if
we make a decision
and and a group of people on the public
want to question it how many signatures
do they have to get to do it if it's
five percent of rate payers and how
practical is it and I feel I need that
information before I can actually
um uh proceed to make a decision here
tonight
think
I might be speaking at a term but I
think ballpark you're probably looking
at about 500 if you are being
conservative and see there's 10 000
voters 500 oh son yes if I might be able
to be of some assistance
um in the last election I'm just looking
on Election nz's website and um we had
4795 votes returned which represented
52.66 percent
voter return subset help yeah
yeah so you're probably looking about
500 then for from 450 500 yeah
500 people yeah
just in terms of I don't want to put you
on the spot here Rex but just in terms
of time frames about having that that
represent representation discussion when
is that likely to happen I'm assuming it
won't be before that that deadline
so again
um
if you look at paragraph two the choice
of the electoral system is not formally
part of a representation review but the
local government commission recommends
it should be considered as part of the
overall review of representation
so it's actually outside of the
representation review doesn't kick into
action until calendar year 2020 whatever
next year is for
um
um sometimes they use drag and sometimes
they race so
um so so the representation review is
not formally getting underway till 2024.
um and there are some quite specific and
and prescribed dates for that which have
come to council previously so in terms
of answering your question your worship
we do this in this time frame because
this is the legislative time frame that
the local electoral act requires us or
requires you to determine by the 12th of
September I think it is from memory
um yeah by the 12th of us of September
this year you've got a resolve whether
you're going to go first past the postal
single transferable it doesn't matter
about the representation review as such
because it's outside of that even though
as we recognize it does have an impact
on and affects the overall review of
representation as you mentioned so it's
a slight technical
misalignment of of law of the law
thank you for that rex that being said I
just recognize that we do actually have
a council meeting on the 12th
um so if we were to scrape and we could
make that decision on the day
um would it be achievable to have a
representation discussion between now
and the 12th of December or September
sorry
um to just give cancer some more context
on that no more than what you've already
had by way of the report that came to
your meeting two or three meetings ago I
I don't know what other representation
review conversation you can have that
would do it justice compared to what
you're going to have to go through next
year
because the the the the the
prescribed process next year is quite
intense and you haven't you you you're
not going to do that because you're
still gonna have to do it next year as
per the local government commission
requirements
thank you for that clarification that
makes a lot of sense Council Dixon
I'd just like to move that the report be
received
and so you would like to table the rest
of it
so you would like to table the rest of
the recommendations or
that the report be received and the
recommendations be received as well okay
so you would like to receive all of the
recommendations confirming first pass
the post
Council Stringer seconded thank you
any further debate
I guess thinking out loud just so comes
in my thinking I think
to summarize that discussion uh if we
were to change the wards while it may be
first post in 2025 it would need to be
re-looked at for 2028 anyway
um so we would be able to see whether
that system's working or not
so I'm comfortable with that as well
Council Phillips
thank you where is it I'm more than
comfortable uh is Paul alluded about the
material community board being in it
being that the material Community award
only make recommendations coming to
council
so if we were to change it it was not
going to make much difference anyway so
that it's only the structure of the
community board rather than
you know first past the post or whether
you know the first person the more
highest voting so
thanks for that counselor
any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against
would you like that recorded
the motion is carried
thank you councilors
uh item number nine uh Southern Museum
and art gallery are there any updates
from the true executive no uh we'll take
the reporters read do we have any
questions for the chief executive on
this report
do we have any discussion on this report
could I please have a move this report
be received
uh councilor MacDonald signaled by
councilor Guardian
any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
uh minutes for the wastek meeting would
the chair of wasting it like to comment
on these minutes at all
thank you you worship wasting it which
is the
um three local authorities territorial
authorities working together for the
supply of Waste Services
has had several very productive meetings
in recent time which are set out in the
agenda or the minutes of those meetings
where we are working together to move
forward to respond to public
issues particularly in relation to
recycling and having common approach
across the whole
region and that we will be continuing to
make progress in that area I think it is
worth highlighting that wastenet has
financial resources available to it that
aren't necessarily available to each of
the constituent councils and we'll be
looking at how we can best
use those to the benefit of The Wider
region
thank you councilor are there any
questions arising from these minutes
can I please remember these minutes be
received
at cancer Garden secret advice
councilor Richard mcvale any further
discussion
all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried number
11 uh minutes of the matoda community
board
with the ward council like to speak to
these minutes at all
I'll just take them as read you worship
um if there's any questions more than
the hyperd answer
thank you councilor after reading
through his minutes I think it's all
pretty standard
do we have any questions for councilor
Phillips on these minutes uh Council
mcfar
yeah through the worship um the timeline
on the sign was the one I was asking
about
um it doesn't come it talks about you
know where it's really about but there's
no
is there an end in sign a science
sorry is there an Eden sign yeah I hope
there's an end
um only in the Roadie manager who's not
prison at the time but maybe one of the
managers may be able to answer that
question but
um I'm unaware of a timeline or Finish
Line at the moment
if you're disappointed I think how do
you think I feel
sorry
just spilling water
um just through your worship I guess um
there has been over the past couple of
months significant progress on the side
and so although this project has been on
uh the books for a long time uh it has
under uh the voting managers careful
Watcher has been progressing I mean we
uh hopeful to get this completed as soon
as possible but there has been uh some
some positive progress which hopefully
is keeping the community board
aware of where things are at
thank you Jason and thank you councilors
I believe the due date was Christmas
last year that one so
any day now would be great
any further questions uh Council
McKenzie
uh
the pit symmetry is there a lot of
support in
in Matera fort
if you had much support
that was one of the projects uh from one
of the board members
um and he believes that there is quite a
group of people out there that are
looking for places for to put their pets
not only do within the material wood but
also the whole District actually
yeah so there was a another report to
come through to the next meeting from
the manager about the aspect of where
they wanted to go in Henderson Park so
we'll just wait until the next meeting
which is on the
31st of this month
we have a few boxes at our house
possibly go there
I'm sure with a small charge I think we
might be able to accommodate you thank
you councilor
thank you councilors any further
comments
could I have a mover that these minutes
be received and that any recommendations
are actioned
Council Stringer seeking by councilor
Phillips
any further discussion I will put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
and against
the motion is carried
a summary of the mural Forum meeting
and now if my recollection serves me
well
I think I must set on the end of this
one
did you have any commentary Council
Hotel
or Steve for this one no fantastic any
questions arising from these minutes
no
I don't think there's a recommendation
here either
the summary so just a question um the
hydrogen Supply from the h
WR group
um I've heard it's going to happen in
the South core how far away is that
in South Gore yeah uh so we're the
Allied petrol stationers
is it Ally two time wise oh time wise
oh I'm not entirely sure actually
um
yeah Joseph Mooney asked me the same
question
um it's they're built off site um and
they basically look like um
big shipping containers
um so whether the one that's there is
part of I'm not too sure but
um I will certainly keep cancers updated
in the public updated on timelines
any further questions
no we'll move on from that minutes of
the creative communities assessment
subcommittee
uh councilor Dixon did you have any
commentary
thank you wish it was just a short
meeting because we didn't have a lot of
funding left for the year
um that we we hope would be able to pass
out to community groups which we did
um yeah it was a successful meeting
and I'll move that the minutes are
turned correct record
I think it's just that they've ever
received but you're fine to move those
uh in a secondary
councilor mcdonell uh any further
questions for Council Dixon
now I will put the motion orders in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried uh
next to the minutes from the Great South
joint shareholder committee meeting
uh which once again I was only there for
half the meeting unfortunately
um but I think the main outcome from
that
um was the discussion
um around a statement before intent uh
being every three years rather than
every year to line up with our long-term
plans rather than great South coming
back to us annually talking about
funding that we the collective actually
allocate Great South funding as part of
our long-term plan so that we all get
our priorities in mind and it saves the
the admin time um for them so there was
some sense across the board in that
regard and we will continue to work on
uh what that looks like hitting heading
down the road
do we have any questions from councilors
on that try my best to answer them
no uh could I have a move that these
minutes be received
uh councilor Phillips and the second uh
Council Dixon
any further conversation
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against motion is carried
and that brings us to the end of the
public portion of the meeting I just
wanted to clarify uh for counselors and
also the public uh that the August
meeting will be canceled this is to
provide
counselors and also staff a mid-year
break after
what has been quite a busy year
and so we will resume in September we
will still be continuing to do ltp
workshops and regular Council business
but for the council meeting itself it
seemed like it was an appropriate time
to take a wee break
with not too much being on our agendas
at the moment
I we will have a quick break in between
the public and the